Kancil culture strikes again going of
food CEO is refusing to apologize in the
face of a liberal boycott of his food
company they're angry after he said
America was quote blessed to have a
leader like president Trump take a look
its suppression of speech in in 2012
eight years ago I was called by Michelle
Obama to Tampa and I introduced at in
Hispanic Heritage Month President Obama
so you know I'm not apologizing for
saying and especially recall by the
president United States you're gonna say
no I'm sorry I'm busy
no thank you I didn't say that to the
Obamas and I didn't say that the
president Trump all right Greg so here
we have a guy who's been to the White
House with Obama White House with Trump
this time he goes in support of the
Hispanic initiative that provides access
to for education and entrepreneurial
outreach and it gives two million cans
of food for those who are needed during
this pandemic does the left hate Donald
Trump so much that they don't want
Hispanics to get help or poor Americans
who are suffering right now to get food
well they will their hatred for Trump
Trump's their love for the poor the best
part about this story one of the
boycotters is lin-manuel miranda whose
play hamilton became a movie and is now
under fire for glorifying a slaveholder
so it shows you what happens when you're
threatened by the mob you either fight
back or you roll over
Miranda full-fledged coward rolled over
and went after Goya foods to save his
own skin but I have a perfect solution
which is courtesy of Scott Adams
canceled cultureworks cuz it's one way
people can cancel you because they know
where you work but you can't cancel back
because you don't know where they work
so we need mutually assured destruction
full transparency where all the canceled
errs we find out where they work and we
so we can contact their companies and
their bosses and ask them here are you
ok with your employee Doris Johnson
trying
ruin a Hispanic run company that feeds
millions for free so we need a company
devoted to outing all the councillors
because people don't punch you if you
can punch back that's right that's right
you get respect from them but you know
Dana the the CEO of Goya says you know
this is suppression of my speech and
he's not backing down what do you think
now well first of all I'm going is it an
amazing company the story of how that
company was built over time is
incredible plus they have amazing
products what is also quite stunning is
that Alexandria Kazuya Cortez is one of
the ones leading the charge on the
boycott against Goya but it was Goya
that was the first to go into the New
York boroughs after the coronavirus
lockdown started and to basically
provide free food to everybody in those
areas so it is absurd of course the
other thing is though when you are a CEO
and you have ten ten thousand employees
that are relying on you you know you can
understand why people might be reticent
to get involved in politics or to say
something about politics I admire him
for not backing down and I don't think
that he regrets it for one instance it
is just too bad that it has to we have
to clarify cancel culture on the backs
of this company which by the way again I
would say their products are excellent I
encourage everyone to go out and get
some they are yeah they are are there
chickpeas are great for homeless all
right Jesse listen 36 percent the polls
say Biden has 36 points over Trump with
a Hispanic community does that make
sense to you well from what I've heard
the the president's making very strong
inroads with the Hispanic community and
it's making up for some of his deficits
in the suburbs with white women so it's
obviously too early to tell but I just
had a brilliant idea it may be the only
brilliant idea I've ever come up with on
the show and Greg kind of teed me up for
it with about the mutually assured
destruction thing you know how you can
buy carbon offsets if you're a polluter
you should just be
by canceled offsets right so like you
could just get away with a lot more if
you just pay the right people anyway
this country Jesse Jesse Jesse that's
called virtue signaling that's why
everybody virtue signals that's their
offset they pay virtue signal they give
money they do whatever they can so they
don't get eaten by the crocodile but
they always do okay I didn't know you
could did yes yes brilliant point here
my nan brilliant point is this this
country is too fat to boycott a food
country a food company have you looked
around like do you think a boycott of a
food company could last like one meal or
two meals I mean this is delicious stuff
the taco kits from soya unbelievable I
mean this is a top ten dinner item for
most families there's no way this thing
is getting boycotted and when you're
when you're a leader of a multi-billion
dollar company in this country you have
to be nice to Republicans you have to be
nice to Democrats because this country
just wants to eat me well that's it it
was but one I want to I want to end this
with you in terms of look the left is so
focused on trashing people on the right
that they don't care that the people
that they presume to be on the right are
helping poor people hungry people
helping immigrants their their hate is
so dug in I mean are you comfortable
with this the right doesn't do this to
Obama and trust me a lot of people on
the right didn't like Obama but this is
like canceled amount boycott them make
them lose their jobs aren't you
uncomfortable with that
I don't like boycotts if that's what
you're asking judge but let me just say
we live in politically polarized times
and if you're talking about who likes
division president Trump's pushes
buttons of division and polarization
quite regular I think you'll remember he
started his campaign by going after
Latin immigrants he said Mexicans were
rapists and thieves so I think to your
point of people punch back
they're people we did well no he didn't
people who will punch back from the
other side so I said to use the very
word racist they're blue don't wanna
hear that's what that is true oh I don't
know what you guys can do you know why
because you know what you guys can do
the batteries you paid your same job
judging enough is it so chip judge yeah
here's the question want the opposite
effect which guess what lots of people
who like President Trump can start by
and goya if that's what they want maybe
they'll like ricin being smothered in
hot sauce I don't know but I'm just
telling you we live in politically
polarized times and we have a
politically polarizing president yet no
we don't he doesn't push buttons
batterers use that excuse all the time
when they beat their wives okay I hate
that term